est une une déclaration qui
manifestement n'est pas exact le rôle de
monsieur benalla au sein de l'elysée il
a été mis en évidence j'allais dire par
la commission denquête tout ça a été
extrêmement floue manifestement fin flou
jusqu'à un certain point
manifestement il s'occupait de la
sécurité du président de la république
et le sénat étaient tout à fait fondés
est parfaitement dans son droit et
essayer de comprendre comment la
sécurité du président de la république
était organisée parce que effectivement
il est enfin il a 26 ans il n'a aucune
expérience en vue d'avoir travaillé dans
des boîtes de sécurité et il se retrouve
en position de donner des ordres ou en
tous les cas de jouer de sa position
vis-à-vis du gspr enfin c'est quand même
incroyable cette histoire incroyable et
lorsqu'on voit le premier ministre
franchement ça va ça m'a choqué choqué
et le premier ministre de la france
sortir sur le perron de l'elysée pour
aller critiquer le travail qui a été
fait par le sénat travaille qui a été
unanimement salué par la presse ce matin
jusqu'à france culture qui dit du bien
du sénat c'est pas tous les jours un
quand même
unanimement saluée et voir le premier
ministre de la france sortir sur le
perron de l'elysée pour essayer de le
dénigrer le travail de cette commission
denquête c'est choquant vraiment c'est
choquant edouard philippe elle n'avait
pas l'air très à l'aise effectivement
dans sa déclaration je sais je sais pas
qui a tenté de le faire ça mais on le
sentait mal à l'aise mais pour l'image
du premier ministre et de la fonction
mais quel naufrage quel naufrage et
cette affaire est un naufrage depuis le
début un naufrage en termes de gestion
de crise un naufrage parce qu'on a
découvert effectivement au coeur même de
l'elysée
les choses étaient faites mais à
l'emporte-pièce et puis c'est vrai que
cette affaire de contrats négociés par
quelqu'un qui est en position à l'elysée
mais c'est gravissime cette affaire là